Rodrigo buenas noches que desde el 2019
cuando bolsonaro asumió el poder en
enero de ese año a la fecha
prácticamente se triplicó el número de
armas en circulación hoy son más de un
millón y duplicó el número de personas
que obtuvieron
registro de cazadores son casi 700.000
un número absurdo Porque por cierto no
se trata de que haya tantos cazadores
sino de personas que usan ese atajo para
estar armados y es posible que a partir
de mañana cuando nula ASUME el gobierno
de transición las medidas de transición
estos sean los primeros anuncios de esa
gestión por supuesto esto Solo se
materializará a partir del primero de
enero cuando el nuevo gobierno entrará
en funciones aquí en Brasil y otra de
las grandes promesas de Lula es la
protección de la amazonía qué
legislaciones han hecho más daño al
respecto de la amazonía estos años y
cuales urge más derogar
básicamente el de restablecer los
controles para impedir que sean
invadidas tierras protegidas y que sean
invadidas también áreas de grupos de
pueblos originarios Esos son los dos
puntos claves prometidos por una que
incluso anunció que va a crear una
autoridad para defensa de la amazonia
una especie de comité independiente del
gobierno y que se prolongará Más allá de
la cuestión tenga en cuenta que por otra
parte Lula la próxima semana no la
entrante la otra viajará Egipto para
tomar parte de la Cumbre ambientalista
cop27 donde posiblemente confirmará
estos anuncios y donde será recibido
prácticamente como un presidente en
funciones porque el actual de ahí
evolucionado Aparentemente no tomará
parte en ese evento
vamos ahora con el secreto de la
información con qué argumentos se impuso
este secreto de 100 años para la
información en Brasil Podría tener
problemas Yair bolsonar o de derogarse
esta ley
en efecto puede ser que esto le cause
algunos problemas porque uno de los que
fue protegido por esta este impedimento
de acceso a la información garantizado
por ley fue el acceso de sus hijos al
palacio del plan alto en particular uno
de ellos Carlos bolsonaro como todo el
mundo sabe aquí de oficio eso no es
oficial
conduciría lo que se llama un gabinete
de la desinformación un gabinete del
odio Desde allí sería donde se organizan
las campañas de desinformación y desde
donde se disparan millones de fake news
a través de las redes sociales esto
preocupa bastante al gobierno y preocupa
en particular a lo que aquí se conoce
como el plan bolsonaro formado por el
mandatario y tres de sus hijos pilares
del actual sistema del poder empieza a
desgastarse obviamente cuando la salida
del mandato está la vista bolsonaro es
el primer presidente democrático desde
1994 que no logró reelegirse y el
levantamiento de estos secretos podría
causarle algunos inconvenientes incluso
otro de ellos es el que él impuso a su
tarjeta de vacunación personal aseguró
que nunca se vacunó contra el
coronavirus sin embargo y dio exigió que
esa información quede por 100 años bajos